[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, everyone.
My name is Maria,
also known as Masha.
I work at Play Games' BD team.
I believe games are art.
I still occasionally play
"Heroes of Might and Magic 3."
And I literally cried with joy
when I opened up all the tiles
in "Thrace."
When I think about the
best games to play,
my mind immediately goes to
unique, deep, more meaningful
experiences-- in other
words, to indie games.
Indie became the genre of
its own in the same way
as [INAUDIBLE] to
an idle clicker,
to shooter, or to an adventure.
And this specific
genre makes people
all over the world really
excited about video games
and motivates them to tweet
to their friends, oh my gosh,
you should totally
check this out.
Today, if indies
didn't exist, we
would only have big
and mainstream games.
And we would live, technically,
in the gamer's horror
"Groundhog Day" where you pretty
much play the same game over
and over again.
But luckily, we do have freedom.
We do have freedom to choose
what games we want to play.
And this freedom is one of the
best and most beautiful things
about video games.
And we should say thank you
to indies for this choice.
Thank you, indies.
[APPLAUSE]
While not everyone can come
up with the next big game
on mobile, it's very
important to support artists
at each stage of
their creative process
and reward them for risks.
On other platforms,
we already saw proof
that indies do not
cannibalize on the success
of mainstream and big titles.
But they coexist in
the comfortable space,
attracting new players
and entertaining
those who are in wait.
They do coexist on PC and
consoles, but not on mobile,
not yet.
So what is Indie Corner?
Indie Corner is the place on
the Play Store ruled by indies.
This is the
destination for players
to discover new games
coming from most
interesting, inspirational,
and talented teams from all
over the world.
This is the place to keep up
to date with most trending,
most talked about, and recently
launched indie releases.
Also, this is the
hall of fame where
players can discover
the true masterpieces
of independent game
development crafted for mobile.
Indie corner includes
three games collections,
which represent three stages of
the success of independent game
developers.
And we would love to support
your team through all
those stages with us.
The first collection is
called new highlights.
This is the section
of the Indie Corner
that helps to solve
discoverability for new teams
when they're launching their
first, and most innovative,
and experimental title.
If you are one of those
teams, stay with me.
In a few minutes, I will tell
you how to get considered.
The second collection
is most popular.
We highlight trending,
recently launched indie
titles that received the highest
user rating and play time.
And with that collection is
a carefully curated showcase
of the most innovative,
noteworthy, critically
acclaimed masterpieces
of the indie space
to keep you inspired
and motivated.
And I'm thrilled to announce
to you that we have already
launched our first
collection on the Play Store.
The collection went
live on February 25,
and we are planning to
update it on a monthly basis.
Besides being just a
showcase, Indie Corner
empowers developers
to take advantage
of existing free
Google Play tools
and to optimize their
presence on the platform.
Player Analytics
provides a better view
into players' behavior and helps
with fine-tuning a free to play
game.
And developers working
on premium titles
can protect their creations
by using Google App licensing.
I'd like to feature a very
passionate and talented team
from Singapore, Springloaded.
This team did a phenomenal
job tuning their game,
"The Last Vikings,"
with actionable feedback
from Player Analytics.
They achieved material
improvements in their KPIs,
as you can see, and received
a feature in Indie Corner.
So how do you get started?
I would like you to take
out your phones right now
and take a picture
of this slide.
Here, you will find the
link to the submission form
to get your game considered
for Indie Corner.
But before you do so, please
review the requirements.
Technically, we want you
to unleash your creativity,
to experiment, to
do something that
has never been seen before.
And we're here to support you.
That's it.
We're excited to see
your submissions.
We are thrilled to grow this
space together with you.
And you can find me
later, during the break
or at roundtables, to ask
any questions and talk more.
And please stay awesome.
Thank you, and play indie.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]